I turn to my right and I look at our
in-studio guests and say his film is
coming out Friday and he's a
first-ballot Pro Football Hall of Famer
I don't know if I've ever said that how
he longs movies haven't come out on a
Friday in quite some time
nope but LaDainian Tomlinson your film
god blessed the broken road is of
opening in theaters on Friday good to
see you LT good to see you rich thank
you you're acting now you first one man
and it was it was pretty awesome I
played a pastor and the film is about a
young woman who loses her husband in
Afghanistan and she falls upon hard
times losing him and trying to raise her
daughter by herself and she goes through
various things like losing her house and
you know it's really a story there
really will inspire and bring hope to a
lot of people and of course playing the
pastor is my job to help her regain her
faith and the her is played by Jordin
Sparks as she and she's in this film she
is in the film but but Jordan is it's
not the the person you're gonna have to
okay gonna have to see it yeah I have to
see the film okay cuz Jordin Sparks is
in it Robin Givens who play my wife in
the film is in the film yes Kim Delaney
who was on NYPD Blue for many many years
she's in this film as well how did you
get involved in this well gentlemen that
I've known for quite some time is it an
executive producer for the fan and so
one day out the blue I hadn't talked to
him and quite some time he called me up
and say LT were casting a for film and
he said we need a pastor he said I
thought of you and he said before you
tell me to screw off just hear me out he
said I think you'll be awesome in this
role send me a script another thing that
he said to me rest was was intriguing to
me and really made me want to do the
film as he said it parts of the proceeds
from this film will benefit DAV disabled
american veterans and of course you know
all the work i doing the community and
huh you know working with our veterans i
had to be a part of that i know you were
exposed to it for many many years in san
diego obviously what type of town San
Diego is God blessed the broken road God
blessed the broken road is in theaters
this Friday we'll talk a bit a little
bit more
about this because I'm wondering if
you're pulling a Jim Brown when you're
running a career all over you started
acting as well I do want to hit you on
some of the headlines going on in the
National Football League what do you
think is going through living on Bell's
mind right now LaDainian Tomlinson yeah
I think Le'Veon understands that for one
this might be as last year and in
Pittsburgh and - I think he wants to
reserve him or preserve himself for
whatever team he goes to next it's no
secret that Pittsburgh is probably going
to run him you know into the ground this
year because this is his last year and
so if you're Lavy on you do need to
preserve yourself and if I was him I
would take my my my you know self out of
the games at times to preserve my
carries because you know you're not the
long-term solution for Pittsburgh inning
loss but but doesn't that what does that
mean for the guys that you're suiting up
with up look I'm always on the side of
somebody getting theirs trying to get
theirs certainly in a sport where your
career can end with the next snap of the
football so I placed that caveat on this
question though if he does want to do
this and that is his right to do for his
career his family his his well-being
what does that mean to the rest of the
Steelers when he's out there I mean what
if he during the game third quarter you
know touch the top of his helmet right
in the middle of a drive because what he
wants to preserve himself for next team
well I don't know if you I don't know if
you're doing it in that way but there
are times where you know say for example
if it's a long drive and typically you
might stay in that long drive you can go
out for two or three plays within that
twelve play drive and preserve yourself
you know it's quite easy to do that you
know is you ever do that um not not on
purpose but you know sometimes you do
need a little breather and of course I
had some great guys behind me so I did
it so I can preserve myself in the
fourth quarter because I knew that that
was when my team
needed me but you know it's
disappointing
what Pittsburgh is doing to be honest
with you because you draft a player
develop dis player to become the best
guy in the league at running the
football but you don't want to pay him
what happened to you know all this stuff
that these organizations sell you on
faith family football and we care about
you but you want to run him into the
ground and and then use him up and not
pay him like that's unfair it does seem
to me that if Khalil Mack was still a
Raider right now and holding out and not
getting his with three years of team
control still left one contractually and
then two years of franchise tagging like
Levien's gotten and he got his exit
visas to the Bears that he might be
thinking that he might be in camp right
now you know I mean like he's looking
that but I don't know do you think the
Steelers would really trade him right
now I mean this is the update they need
him this year they need him well they're
not asked acting like they're needed you
know because you could've did this a
long time you could have traded him if
you knew you weren't gonna sign him to a
long-term deal that is totally unfair to
try to use a player up and just get rid
of him that I mean just trade him get
rid of him just like Oakland did with
with Khalil LaDainian Tomlinson here on
the Rich Eisen show again um what what
were the numbers for him last year
number of ties 321 carries 406 touches
so they kind of ran him in the ground
last year anyway so that's what I'm
saying since what would it what would
those numbers look like running it into
the ground 350 calories and you know I
don't you touches again yeah that would
qualify as running it into the ground
does this at all make you rethink the
Steelers Super Bowl viability the fact
that he's not in camp right now week one
on the Wednesday before even if he does
show up even if he does show up say
Friday Saturday so he can get his game
checked this week yeah what do you think
um yes it does because he's a special
talent he's a
a special weapon on that team as part of
that offense and he's a premier player
you win games with players not coaches
and in the thing about it is that's why
it's intriguing to me what Oakland did
because they traded away their best
player and in this sense in the same way
I mean you can make the argument that
Antonio Browns possibly their best
player but Le'Veon is you know he's top
actually absolutely right when a issue
want to be right there so what do you
think is going on in the Raiders locker
room right now though oh you know I
think a lot of players are disappointed
because you know Khalil helps everybody
on that defense and think about the
other pass rushers like Bruce Irvin
remember how easy Bruce Irvin had it
because of Kalia he didn't get
double-team but now protections are
gonna slide to him because he's the most
dominant Russia they have what do you
think those guys in the secondary are
thinking you know if we're not getting
no pressure on the quarterback it's
gonna be tough to cover guys beyond that
rich he was one of the leaders in the
locker room that was the thing that we
heard coming out of that locker room a
lot in Oakland Khalil was a leader it
was best friends with Derek Carr all of
that will have effect on that locker
room trust me yeah and then the fact
that there's 31 new members on the team
right now and they've made it in the
mold I guess of Gruden who loves
veterans right and their average age is
over the age of 27 oldest roster and
then that gives you the idea we kind of
need to win right now with the veterans
and they trade Khalil Mack but they also
what if that Steelers just went up and
traded levy on bill basically saying
addition by subtraction we're not gonna
think about it anymore we're gonna give
him his exit visas we're gonna figure it
out I mean what's the right thing to do
so the secularist locker room would be
fine with that well I think with those
guys and hearing them talk over the last
couple of days I think they're fine they
believe in James Connor James has had a
really good preseason and he's
progressed very nicely now he's he
Le'Veon Bell absolutely
not but you know he can be a solid
version of Le'Veon because he is a guy
that can run between the tackles he's
tough he can catch the ball out the
backfield and so who knows what he's
gonna develop into but I think he's
earned the confidence of everybody in
their locker room but with all due
respect what do you know about preseason
football no did you ever play it down a
precinct I did a dip was the last down a
preseason footnote for the Jets did you
know actually yeah my first year I
remember Rex Ryan wanted to kind of see
what I had and and I played against the
Giants well he played everyone in the
Snoopy ball he played Sanchez in the
fourth quarter we all know what happened
there yeah so did you tell Rex look I
don't know what this pre what is this
preseason salutely not you know he
wanted to see what the old man had and I
was willing to give it to him ok ok it's
just interesting that it seems that
everybody's taking your old or the lates
the old approach that the Chargers took
with you the preseason there's no reason
to play
there's no reason like it doesn't mean
anything right and you know you I feel
bad for guy like guys you know to
Washington rookie running back plays in
pre-season that his season is over and
even Jerry McKinney yep you know that's
just sad to see and it happens quite
often
butch LaDainian Tomlinson here on the
Rich Eisen show a few more minutes with
him here in studio your Super Bowl
prediction have you made one yeah I have
what do you got I got charges in and
Vikings chargers Vikings yeah ok let's
take it one at a time here Chargers I
know that's part of his your heart here
but walk me through the head my own this
is the analyst analyst hat yeah ok and
so we're looking at a team that in the
AFC now yes what our question is one of
the strongest on paper barring injury
you have one of the top quarterbacks and
Phillip Rivers who's primed and ready to
have you know an all-time great season
right Keenan Allen who every year he's
gonna have 100 catches Mike Williams the
emergence of microwaves ok along with
some of the other guys on offense Mike
Pouncy to the addition of Mike policy
is gonna have the run game Melvin Gordon
would get get going and then you you
coupled that with a defense that's had
has gotten better you got to still pass
rushers but then you got a young rookie
stud you drafted to in Derwin James
that's gonna help that secondary sauce
you have everything you need and you
have depth and Kaleb Sturgis he's the
kicker now so you said you said two
words that I've rarely here with about
Chargers the words barring injury
usually there's no barring you know and
we already saw that with Hunter Henry
yeah but you're right I mean Phillip has
got some weapons here and then Gordon is
as good as they come gates just did the
old man thing which is I don't need no
stinking preseason a training camp I'll
just show up and I'll just run my routes
here okay and then the Vikings yes do
you think Cousins is gonna perform
better than Case Keenum well it's as
simple as that yeah i but but i also
think they're one of the most well
coached teams i loves him i think he's
an excellent coach but that defense i
believe will be better they kept the
nucleus together on defense they would
be dominant again but then Kurt cousins
just I think he's gonna boost the
confidence of everybody on offense but
the key and the key is Dalvin cook you
know have endowment cook an explosive
dynamic player that can take it to the
house at any point on the field that's
gonna be the difference I'll tell you
last night on gameday morning Season
Preview I gave my Super Bowl prediction
and I tried so many different ways to
figure out how the Patriots aren't
making it back just just to make it
interesting right couldn't figure it out
with all due respect to the Chargers the
Texans who I think will have the MVP on
the team I think deshaun Watson is gonna
be the MVP of 2018 well we saw last year
in October I do not think was an outlier
at all I think it was the future of this
game and I think he is going to ball out
if he's barring injury be the MVP of the
league and then maybe even win in Week
one a new
England as the do your job Patriots will
have their usual September trying to
figure out how to work it together and
then Belichick will figure it out and I
think New England makes it well you know
they're right they got the easiest pants
they're probably gonna win the AFC East
I don't know that you could take the
probably out of it and so if that's the
case what do you typically have when you
win your division by week about week and
then that next game is at home and we
know how hard it is to win at Gillette
Stadium it's almost it's very difficult
you know of course I did it with the
Jets though the jet yeah right with the
Jets
that's the can't wait game right isn't
that what that is that was before there
was oh the Bart Scott can't wait and
then he act they yeah got it done and
then um for the NFC I love Atlanta
because they're paid they're all paid
and happy yeah well there's six teams
that you can save right no I know that
but I I eventually settled on the Rams
see I really just settled on the Rams on
paper they are so damn talented and
McVeigh and Wade Phillips know how to
take the paper and put it into human
practice and I just I just really think
that Gurley is gonna be one a ish in the
MVP race this year yeah and I just like
the Rams beating New England in Atlanta
and winning it all the Rams just because
I always being uh you know the role that
I have on the NFL Network I always look
for storylines cuz you know this the
football gods always like laughing and
they wink and not at you and you don't
expect it the rams lone Super Bowl win
was when they christened the Georgia
Dome and now this is the new place in
Atlanta so they're gonna be there in
Atlanta and do it again okay
so I think that's gonna be the Rams
beating the Patriots and what could
possibly be Brady's last Super Bowl you
never know and as we know Brady beat the
Rams for his first Super Bowl it's kind
of bookending in a way you've dumped all
this out this is what I do for a living
what Danian you know you you forgot
above you analyze and act III think
about this frequently useless
information
but on a show like this I hope it's it's
some sort of currency you know so my
only concern can I give you my only
concern with the Rams please okay so I
love their team but can they come
together with all the different moving
parts into different personalities of
talent that they have on that team will
they come together then that was one of
the things that at the at the root of
our problem with the Jets my first year
remember we brought in all this talent
you know and when it came down to it in
the championship game we were already I
guess
personality-wise struggling a little bit
with different dynamics on the team
trying to keep that team together of
course it all fell apart there following
year yes if you remember so then what
was that isn't that coaching isn't that
the coach's job to mix it all together
well yeah it is but the coach can't be
everywhere and you know the coach is not
in the locker room at time when guys are
arguing and saying screw you and you
know what was going on in the chest
locker I mean there was different things
telling each other to go well there was
different things we need names remember
the guys we had I know there's Bart
Scott and then there was sense on your
home's umbrella networks and okay this
is the same Braylon edwards that just
hit Send on Twitter so that was what was
all going on well it was a michigan ohio
state rivalry it was interesting to say
that on top of that the influence that
you know veteran guys sometimes have on
young guys and but that's my only
concern with the Rams will they be able
to keep it together with so many
different dynamics I just done waiting
and waiting because I'm looking at the
personalities and they're all on the
defensive side of the ball okay with a
keep to leave and Marcus Peterson and
Dhamma can sue all just at it if I'm
gonna put some names to what I'm what
you're what you're putting down I'm
trying to pick up
I just think Wade Phillips is gonna
handle that ground weight and yes I do
think he's an excellent defensive
coordinator and coach is there a but
well no I was just gonna say you know
Wade is
is more of you know a father figure he's
not gonna really you know chastise guys
who is that guy so they're gonna have to
have a guy to do that
pull them guys all together because what
happened with one game what if they're
just kidding smoked in you know the
defense is getting brand through and
they can't figure it out their day and
that when one and one one corners
throwing a flag another corner snatching
it you know that defensive lineman is
stopping somebody absolutely you're
saying yeah I'm still going with I'm
still going Rams over Patriots but you
never know who's your MVP choice do you
think I think Aaron Rodgers it's tough
not to go there he's gonna have an X
Games oh good so good so before I let
what do you gotta stay healthy I know
yeah before I let you go god blessed the
broken road again is in theaters this
Friday a moving film that you in which
you play the preacher yeah okay it's
just the first of many did you get your
taste of the acting I want to try some
more well we'll see what happens I think
there are other opportunities out there
for me okay and we'll see what happens
okay you know we've had people come on
here and get other seasons picked up and
Oscars one and Emmys one so I'm just
saying you came to the right place come
by see okay and it's you and prime again
right yes gameday prime coming up after
Sunday Night Football
yep and I'll say it I'm I think it's out
there it's you in prime and sharp yeah
and charissa Thompson yes on a simulcast
on Fox am I breaking news town's like a
fun show I saw the tweet yesterday okay
very good
count had tweeted it really yes okay so
you and prime and Shannon Sharpe that's
gonna be good luck to Karissa
three guys jackets that'll be yeah three
guys in jackets yeah three guys in
first-ballot jackets I believe it was
she was shining the first ballot I don't
know I think of course I think he was
I think he was you and Prime going at it
one last one for you and you could you
could you could well I'm just asking you
point-blank what was it like in Canton
this year with the non tio show and what
it was like talking amongst all the Hall
of Famers about that it was very
interesting you know talking to all the
fame Famers about there was various
opinions about of course some guys felt
like that he was basically disrespecting
the Hall of Fame and the players the
guys that have been in shrine and other
guys said hey when he comes we're gonna
welcome him with open arms and I kind of
take that approach right you know
because whatever tio is dealing with
within himself I do believe he's taking
a blame out on the wrong guys we all
know he's mad at the writers which the
players had nothing to do with that but
once he gets over that and he wants to
come back we're gonna welcome him and
you know it was it was sad missing that
missing him and no hey at the end of the
day I think it's something he's gonna
regret regret because you don't get that
back you don't have a change I'd be
enshrining you told this great story if
I you don't mind in the few minutes we
have left here of just recounting for
the audience here of when you first
realize in your enshrinement weekend
that this was a a wonderful weekend and
a totally new experience for you as a
football player and somebody was hoping
to get in when you got to that Hall of
Fame state of the hall yeah
speech and you sat down yeah I was one
of the first ones to go in their room
Safra it's the Friday of the jump off
the weekend where they give the State of
the Hall address president David Baker
does it and so all the Hall of Famers
come into the room and I'm sitting there
the first one and as the guys started to
roll in Jim Brown comes in and he's he's
walking over and he's looking right at
me and I'm thinking is Jim Brown gonna
sit by me and he comes and he sits right
next to me and
first thing he says to me he leans over
and he says you know we you get here
we're all equal and I was thinking to
myself are you kidding me this is for
real and I said no disrespect mr. brown
but we're not all equal you're Jim Brown
you're the Godfather what'd he say to
that he just kind of chocolate a little
bit you know yeah he was I mean that's
that I mean ah the whole ton deity
do you hear that from him just sitting
there and then just in terms of you know
moments that we've seen for the past few
years of the enshrinement ceremony you
know an indelible images of you removing
the coverage of your bust using the tear
drop evident which I got who was the one
who told you yeah I got that idea from
yours truly rich eyes right here on the
reality show yes run tell that is all
I'm saying
tell that good to see you
Thank You Hamilton great to see you as
always at LT underscore 21 on Twitter
and go check out God blessed the broken
road in theaters this Friday you're the
best thank you the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience